The jogan Experience look at North Korea
mhm if you want to see that's the best
example you know if you want to see a
state where I mean we have very little
news from there very few people get out
but the ones that do it's horrific
George Orwells 1984 it it's it's
happening right now somewhere and not
yeah I mean I kind of thought that was
like an interesting idea on America's
original
sin is
slavery and there's no way to change the
past
but one thing you could do if you can't
work out reparations and people don't
seem to be able to work out what to do
with that but one thing you could do is
make America's foreign policy why don't
we just stop slavery who couldn't get
behind that right globally to say we
just you've got you've got an incredible
military there's Injustice going on in
the world that idea of being the world's
policeman I don't know I mean freeing
slaves who could disagree with that well
who's putting up a case against it the
problem is that you're addressing the
way the United States interfaces with
the world as if we're just trying to do
overall good that's not really what
happens with this whole empire building
thing it's what what what's really going
on is controlling resources and coming
up with some reason that you have to
intervene in order to acquire these
resources or control these resources or
protect your resources I think it's uh
you know what I think that is short
money mhm short money cuz what's a
resource there's things that are
resources now that won't be in 20 years
you know what the biggest industry in
the world was in
1903 beavers very close I will give you
I give you I'll give you a I'll pass you
I'll give you a c whaling was the
biggest industry in the world in 1903
and whaling disappeared overnight like
in a year and a half it was gone those
towns were just emptied because the
whale oil wasn't required
anymore because suddenly we discovered
petrochemical too petrochemicals was
really thing yeah the whale oil uh
electricity Edison all of that stuff for
Tesla it's really interesting how that
that industry just fell away it's like
the story of um uh HSE manure in New
York City you know this no so horse
manure you know the why the Brownstones
have got steps up to the front door you
ever wondered about that why is the
ground floor not on the ground floor why
is it up steps why hor [__] really there
was horseshit everywhere they've always
got those metal scrapers by the side and
the yeah to get the horeshit off you
know the old movies they always talk
about smelling salts there's a lot of
references to smelling salts yeah the
smell was horrific if a horse died in
the street you had to wait for it to
atropy to cut it up and take it away New
York was the sound Cobble streets metal
wheels on the carts every horses
everywhere so they made a law to say
right horses were going to put a tax on
them didn't change anything made another
law the next year we're doubling the
taxes right we're going to do a thing
with uh we're going to say if you have a
horse then you have to do this you have
to do that whatever it was
it kept on kept on kept on and what
stopped it Henry
Ford cars came along all gone oh there's
five of them left in Central Park right
all gone in no time wailing disappeared
over the night that thing of like what's
a resource now America trying to get
resources
overseas I mean I don't want to sound
like a Boy Scout I think freeing slaves
would be a much better thing to do than
trying to get control of an oil field
somewhere where you go that's not going
to be a resource in 10 years time yeah
the problem is it's a resource now and
it's a phenomenal one in terms of the
amount of money that you could acquire
but I mean Cobalt wasn't a resource
right 20 years ago and now we really
need Cobalt and suddenly I mean the
things that are happening to get it are
just horrific yeah I had sadar Cara on
the podcast he's a journalist that went
to the Congo to document this and
brought back video footage the
Democratic Republic of Congo mhm any
country with Democratic in the name
that's [__] red flag isn't it that's a
red flag they go hey we're Democratic
are you though are you yeah it's I mean
it's it's hell on Earth out there it's
happening right now I think that think
of like people saying well I would I
would go and make a difference well
there's stuff going on now if you want
to get involved well what's so ironic is
that it's one of the most horrific
conditions that human beings are imposed
that's imposed upon human beings but yet
it is required in order for you to have
a cell phone and complain about the
injustices of the world every single
person that has one of these things you
you have in it minerals that were carved
out of the ground by people living in
the most insane condition child labor
slavery I mean slavery and and not just
that like people with babies on their
back that are breathing in this Cobalt
dust
horrific uh Health consequences
everything all the above abject poverty
no electricity I mean his like the big
thing in the I mean again gratitude go
back to gratitude we we don't live there
uh anyone listening to a podcast is you
know we're doing great what can we do
about it I don't know I mean this is
part of the anxiety of the modern world
because we're surrounded by problems
told about problems that we can have we
have no agency there yeah we can't sort
of do anything but it's I don't know I
mean it's what's going to be the next
resource because environmentalism is
clearly their right yeah this fossil
fuels it needs to stop but we've already
got the downside volatility from
splitting the atom we've already got all
the weapons we could already destroy the
world we've got all of that why are we
not building the tests have been done
right there's nuclear submarines mhm you
know what the range is on a nuclear
submarine yeah it's insane it's
unlimited it's unlimited they can go
forever I mean it's it's crazy why isn't
every town powered by one of those yes
well people have this bad taste in their
mouth because of the few disas disasters
that have existed when nuclear power was
not fuk Fukushima right yeah what's the
death toll on Fukushima it's very low
but the toxic pollution might I think
it's one person but the the toxic
environmental effect of them not being
able to shut down that reactor is pretty
devastating yeah yeah I tell you what
it's not as devastating as fossil fuels
so it's it's as opposed to what is
always the question burning coal right
so burning coal endlessly burn Co and
anyone that says the environmental
problem can be fixed by us cutting back
is Living in a Dream World right because
you go well you can't deny
like that we owe a debt to Future
generations and we owe a debt to people
that are in different geographies to us
like there's no way you can say with
good conscience well you need to cut
back China and India you you I mean most
people in the world third of third of
the world don't have flushing toilets
right like they're living in poverty mhm
so the idea that they won't need energy
is insane insane and we've nailed the
technology and we just
never we got we got nervous but there
worse than that Germany shut down their
nuclear power plants I mean people have
shut them down because there's this
there's this negative connotation
there's this negative association that
people have with nuclear well I mean I
don't know about
um I'm not an expert but Fukushima I
think was a 40-year-old technology yes
there is new tech in that now yes oh
yeah I mean I can't understand why like
the big oil
companies why isn't someone like instead
of just going you've got to every time
there's an oil spill you've got to clean
up the seabirds better or you know the
the Gulf of Mexico disaster was horrific
what happened because go why don't you
just say you got to invest half of your
profits in
nuclear take it private private seems to
get things done quicker than governments
yeah the the real problem is there's
still an insane amount of money to be
made from fossil fuels you know that
there's a desire for it and there's a
market for it and people are already
making money doing it I I don't know
though but okay so if you want ants put
down sugar M the incentives need to be
there so yeah so let's put down some BP
could be the next traditional oil major
to invest in the quickly evolving
nuclear fusion sector I mean join a list
of companies including Chevron and but
that happened after I said it right May
19th I said what few months ago ah CH
changed the date Jesus um that would I
think that's kind of the because those
guys you go would you buy stock in Shell
Oil today I wouldn't CU if you like if
you were buying stocks and you said I'm
going to leave my kids a bunch of stocks
and shares what do I think is going to
be there in 30 years time
yeah I'm I'm sure and I don't know
whether it'll be like someone gluing
themselves to a a jumbo jet I think it's
going to be it's going to be someone
goes there's more money to be made like
in New York with Henry Ford and like the
whaling industry th you know if those
guys want to make money they went and
they worked for
rockella